bavarder rigoler et surtout partager en
jardinant c'est désormais possible
à l'ehpad leval bièvre l'institut
accueille depuis septembre dernier un
jardin partagé
le concept original permet de créer du
lien
l'idée est simple en fait on s'est dit
que on allait mettre à disposition une
partie de notre terrain pour des
personnes qui ne nous connaissaient pas
en se disant qu'on attendait rien en
retour et puis le pari c'est de se dire
que nécessairement ils vont nous
apporter quelque chose et ils vont
apporter quelque chose aux résidents et
aux personnes âgées dans l'établissement
le jardin partagé est proposée par
l'association les colibris avec en ligne
de mire une société écologique et
humaine en ce sens elle espère
accompagner les résidants et là en fait
c'est quelque chose qu'on a tous
découvert après coup le lien social avec
les personnes âgées dépendantes et ça
c'était quelque chose qui a pris une
grosse grosse ampleur pour nous c'est à
dire que maintenant on essaie de mettre
en place des choses qui permettent aux
personnes aux résidents de l'ehpad
devenir jardinier avec nous vous avez
perdu votre nez rouge
des rires et des blagues les résidents
de l'ehpad satisfait par l'initiative
ont ainsi l'occasion de révéler leurs
talents de jardinier
geraghty sais j'ai laissé une partie est
plus de dix ans que j'ai participé à une
petite plantation
ça donne des possibilités aux résidents
aussi de regarder de voir deux de ses ex
premier quoi aussi la collaboration de
l'ehpad et des colibris et positive de
prochain projet d'atelier promettent de
voir le jour au début de l'année 2018